this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
good afternoon everybody welcome to
drama in the sabi sands where it is a 34
degrees Celsius that's about 87 fair
enough I forget I do apologize my name
is Steve welcome and I'm joined by
beacon camera and it is a wonderful
afternoon albeit a little bit warm
please send through your questions
hashtag safari lab or fur them in the
YouTube chat stream we'd love to hear
from you my my plan this afternoon I
just found some elephant tracks and they
head up to the north wastes and solder
on Sydney's dam see if we can catch up
with him alternates with him in a bid do
big loop around because they were
reports of an injured cheetah on the
property at some point this morning I'm
just trying a clarification of where
that individual was but wouldn't that be
something to see so jump on board let's
go and see what we can find when it's
hot like this the animals as always
gonna be by the water so let's check all
the watering points and see if we can be
lucky on this road now we're on up east
on our Western Road there's lots of
tracks of seemingly hooker moody and
those of you who missed the show this
morning or anything last night we're who
Komori on them last night and this
morning and he was calling so Tenggara
popped in at some point last night's let
me show you on the map where is my map
because I've just found these tracks and
they are they seem fresh but they're not
that fresh okay here we go we are over
here on or breeze road and there are
tracks of a male leopard coming down
very very deliberately down this boat
and thats in Gardez tracks were on
Galago coming down all the way and who
Komori we found this morning came
running towards us over here so the good
chance it's somewhere over here in the
middle of the night while no one was
listening and the two of them had some
form of interaction albeit maybe just
calling and shouting at each other but
it's what leopards will often do they'll
demarcate a line
walk along that line and then cross it
and that seems to be what's happened
because hukum or his walk straight down
this one let me just show you again on
the map who Kumar is walk straight down
here he's straight down there straight
through the middle and then he came down
here and out and then Ghana and did
something similar except he went that
way all the way across and down and then
out over there
so they seem to have sort of murdered
each other in a parallel line
demarcating territory as they go so that
is what's interesting we didn't see
anything but that is often what happens
with male lipids it's all about
intimidation it's all about strength and
shouting and calling and leaving the
scent marks behind and we're trying to
see if we can smell any of them because
it's such a lovely snow leopard urine
but anyway while we continue on in
search of these elephants let's go up to
the masai mara and say a very good day
to David very good everybody and Jambo
Jambo from Kenya we are in the Mara
triangle and my name is David and come
with me today is Archie Archie hiding
sir Oh looks good and I'm not sure I'll
be talking about leopards myself I'll be
talking about lions I mean I got better
chances of seeing lions and leopards
although once in a while we get
surprises and we bump into loafers like
the other day I saw that chef a tree may
lay upon and I was very excited well my
plans today
eat to go to the sausage republic since
the republic is an area that you should
see a pride of lions that we call the
sausage it's a pride and he still a
rather hot at the moment here we are
talking of 89 degrees Fahrenheit and 32
degrees Celsius that is very hot and the
reason it's hot it's because in the next
few weeks we shall be getting our long
range so that's how it goes the
temperatures are all is going like this
that that when they stabilize then what
is that coming down
there rains come so the summer plans for
today and remember I'm sure Steve
already told you our joy is always to
get questions and comments from you
hashtag a Safari live on Twitter as
usual and that keeps us going we are
always very interactive and when we hear
your voices and you know getting
questions from your comments it gives us
more spirit to keep looking for animals
at the moment I am driving south east
and that's the road that takes me to
those sausages that I love all those
lions that allowed yesterday I was there
the whole afternoon and for three hours
I did not see anything that related to a
lion for whole three hours now one of
the main reasons I want to keep going
back there or why I go there almost
every other day of that particular
Friday there is one that is called a
king tell that's good
running cabs and nobody nobody I've seen
those cups because I go there every day
and they good friends of mine were
suppose it every day and I also got the
game Rangers who are always in that
project area and you're always in touch
and every two days which he kicked him
out you know joining the other females
for a little walk or for a drink or for
having or you know being involved in a
kill or being in a kill eating but no
Cubs have been seen about two weeks ago
I identified her dead we don't say a
hundred percent that was a ten she went
in a place that he could not see her and
a few minutes later I could hear the
small Cubs you know talking to mama now
I got a feeling she has moved her den to
a new area and that is where I do not
know
but I'm not worried it's by going there
every other day that we'll be able to
see them very good very good so our
children but again as I have always age
on my whether I could bump into anything
on the way and a part for myself and
Steve I think Holly is out about and
you'd like to say jumbo to all of you
good afternoon everyone lovely to have
you on board
on a day it feels that we are pretty
much in the middle part of a volcano
because it's so hot so we've gotten very
lucky today we were actually set out to
go and look for the new hyena den for
the Juma clan and it seems that
according to you the directions that we
got given it is somewhere in here and
not too far but it's a good thing that
we have found a hyena lying down there
already so not too bad for a start of
our afternoon
seems like this morning as Steve was
looking or following hookah Murray then
he came across the Juma clan which is
pretty good news because everyone's been
desperate to be able to find the new den
now please remember that we are live and
interactive so if you've got any
questions or comments you can send them
through using the hashtag Safari live on
Twitter or you can just send us a
comment using the @fc on the YouTube
chat oh you I have actually got the best
part there hello because it is hot today
and it's a lot better in the shade than
what we are feeling right now so as you
can see a lot of the animals are gonna
be doing just exactly this is this
beautiful hyena is I'm just lying where
it's nice and cool where they don't
really have to worry too much and then
they were all gone into is almost sort
of a coma okay I was trying to get a
closer look because there's a lot of
glare going on I'm not too sure if which
hyena this is I would say maybe one of
the females but I mean a little bit hard
to tell because also I'm looking at her
through a screen just to try and see her
better but if you guys know are the
people that have been watching for a
while if you guys know which hyena this
is please do tell us using the hashtag
Safari a lot is I would love to catch up
and to remember who's who and what's
been going on it's been quite a while
since I last saw the hyena so I'm quite
excited and quite hopeful that they'll
have their den somewhere around here now
I see a chair my mouse in the distance
and I wonder if perhaps that's not the
one so I think let's just go around and
we're gonna leave her here we know that
this had particular her you know chances
are that it's not gonna go anywhere and
if it does there are a few mud wallows
around here there's one just in front
here to the left
and then there's another one to the
right so hopefully it will go in there
Jennifer and potentially to the other
reserves that are around us the hyena
clan of the world the Juma clan is known
as the Juma clan just because they tend
to spend a lot of time here so if there
is if it's not a habitual for them to
actually be in another spot then they'll
potentially everybody will know them as
the Juna clan but again depends on the
reserves a lot of times other reserves
will name them differently but
unfortunately with hyenas not too many
people take too much of an interest in
terms of the writing community around
here and then sometimes people just will
refer to them as a clan of hyenas now I
think this is roughly where Steve
mentioned where it is and I can see some
old vehicle trucks and then if you see
in front of us there's a big termite
mound so I wonder if this is actually
not the spot or the termite mound that
they've been using so I just want to go
around see if there's anything around
there that might indicate okay well
there's a nice big hole in there I would
have mentioned this is the this is the
den now that is what I presume to be the
hole though doesn't look that used and
you see there's a lot of grass in front
so I would imagine that if there's all
that grass in there that potentially the
hyenas haven't been coming in and out
because we've got little ones and if
it's quite a busy den then you'll see a
lot of tracks and movements in the room
have grass growing in the front now I am
roughly in the area so we're gonna carry
on looking see if perhaps there's
another entrance onto the other side of
this boundary perhaps that's the one
that they've been using if not according
to the directions we got we shouldn't be
too far maybe there's gonna be another
round around here that might indicate
where the hyenas are this book looks
more like it alrighty yeah
looks definitely more like it now you
see this entrance over here so this
particular entrance compared to the one
that we just saw it's it seems like it's
been used a lot more you see how there's
very little grass around a bunch of new
tracks all around there and then you can
just tell that there's been excavated
you see the black there at the back and
then in there inside of the termite
mound
there's probably where the little ones
are I'm not too sure how many I think
they manage to have a glimpse of one
today I believe Cokie was the hyena that
was around this morning so I have a very
strong suspicion that if there are
little ones around they are in there and
I mean it is as we were saying it's so
hot this afternoon it's about I think I
was saying 33 and we refused to accept
that answer we said it was about 36
degrees Celsius so I'm pretty sure the
little ones are inside well not only for
protection because the termite mound is
their safe place where they hide but
also it's a it's a lot cooler in there
so all the little ones are being clever
already and they've got one point on
humanity so hyenas one humans not not
even zero because we are still very hot
and they're all in there enjoying the
cool afternoon right we're gonna leave
them around we're gonna try and take a
little bit later see if perhaps we can
come across the hyenas but in the
meantime we'll send you guys across to
David who's also looking for hyenas but
all the way in Kenya well gentlemen as I
said earlier I could be heading to look
for lions but always along the way so
many things do happen now I have found
this particular ostrich and yet she put
some cheeks if you look carefully in the
grass there you can see some smaller
heads or smaller birds just meandering
through the grass and that is I would
guess their mother or that's the female
ostrich there and this is the Messiah
ostrich and one who can tell the height
of the grass see that it's covering all
her legs you can see her legs all the
way to the thighs and what I'm trying to
do is see if I could go a little closer
so that you can see those cheeks he's an
ostrich I've been following for quite
some time
initially started with about 12 chicks
when she first hatched and then she lost
- and I think she listened yeah 11 she
lost - she was left at 9 but as she lost
rather - she was less than seven and
last month she lost - and she is now
less with five or less than five but
something tells me these five chances
are we'll make it which is very slowly
try and sneak on her I might be a little
quiet just look at that beauty
yes I'm in the final controls is that's
pretty awesome and I mean we got
ostriches all of Africa but sometimes
they tend to disappear or they tend not
to be where we are you know game driving
looking for animals on good days we are
always lucky to see them now the last
two times I've seen his female she has
been alone and not with male and when
they hatch out on the incubating their
eggs you'll get the males incubating the
eggs during the night and the females in
during the day
for the obvious reason blending I mean
the mayor's blend better at night and he
looked at the color of that female and
see the brown and imagine the color of
the grass or the color of the soil
she'll definitely blend in very well as
she lays over her eggs in during the day
well she got her mouth open as artists
we knew there and that is an indication
that she is quite what you remember say
the temperatures when high 80s now I
would say Nancy you'd like to know what
ostriches eat I would say ostriches
omnivores I mean like most birds you see
how they're flapping the wings there
Nancy it's just because of how hot it is
at the moment I mean Nancy I'll tell you
ostriches are omnivores now let's first
look how they fare as vegetarians if you
read them carefully they're feeding on
seeds of some kind or seeds from the
grass they also feed on any fruit that
they might speak as they walk through
they'll pick small leaves and they also
eat actually blades of gas
so what grass what basically I'm saying
there are vegetarians in that sense but
apart from that they also will be seen
eating small reptiles talk of lizards
talk of small chameleons should I even
get you know snakes will feed on them
and they also feed on all sorts of
insects they catch their locusts
grasshoppers anything of that sort but
Nancy you know just to let you know I
like chicken or like
that got what you call a crop ostriches
do not have a crop but they got a
particular very special stomach that he
also gets in a chicken that is called a
gizzard and that gizzard has very
muscular walls and for food to be
digested there they'll always we have
seen ostriches picking smaller pebbles
in the ground literally speaks more
loose particles of sand which will help
digest other food in the gizzard now the
five chicks that you see they are
apparently there could be both males and
females when we look at birds look at
the sexual dimorphism ostriches you can
tell you know female is a brown or gray
in color and there's black and white in
color but now at that particular age
when they are you know that's the five
of them there it's difficult to tell
whereas from females but anything like
going to eight months or so they start
changing the feathers and the boys you
start you know showing different
feathers for black and white and the
females will remain the same color well
I'm delighted to see these chicks that
had not seen for about two weeks now
just carry on going back to look for my
lions and I think Steve is working very
hard to look for some cuts
thanks David while we are melting in the
seat right now it is hot it might not
look that hot spread your it is that's
taylor's your I think she did it entire
half in our segment on the correct use
of the word your I'm not going to
enlighten you because it's basically
it's just that Wow
but more so South African slang your hey
beak a very commonly used and it can
mean many things the heightening of any
sort of thing a exclamation exclamation
triple exclamation on the end your
anyway we found that we went around
Sydney's damn nothing going on there
there was a herd of Impala in the
distance oh just enjoying some shade
just like we're about to who what would
we do without the trees I think we'd all
just be melting when we are melting and
then I had some buffalo jacks coming in
and they went towards a small little pan
just over there but no luck finding them
only about three maybe four Buffalo
Bulls coming in probably trying to avoid
the Oklahoma pride
so the elephants have come up and down
there's some fresh tracks coming back in
and South again and we're going to see
if we can follow them but talking about
Buffalo and their favorite or should I
say the predator that loves them so much
on this property it seems like Ellie has
caught up with and Google the pride we
do they seem to love Buffalo and
apparently they had a wonderful morning
today we all know that they got full
bellies which is good news because I
think we were all concerned that they
were looking a little bit hungry now
they are on a property that we
unfortunately cannot go into so we're
looking at them from quite a distance he
can see just how far away and how well
this lioness is blending with the
environment so I think it was a very
good thing that she is very hot and
panting cos and she's got her head up
and that made it a little bit easier for
us to see there is a pan or well more
like a mud wallow not too far from where
she is so if she gets really really hot
she can go down in there and have a
drink
we the rest of the pride is here I'm not
too sure how many of them cuz we can
only see a few heads far behind from
where she is hiding behind a tree so
it's a little bit tricky trying to put
the rest of them on camera just try to
say I was doing it well you see that
bush in the middle of your frame there
behind it yeah they're behind there
somewhere all lying down because it's
very hot so there by the shade of a big
tree which is very clever of them so as
I was saying oh yeah I feel like I feel
like the Lions are being very clever in
not just alliance of hyenas clearly as
well but all the animals are a little
bit more clever than us humans driving
around in the heat but the good thing
about the heat is that because it makes
animals be a little bit more static if I
can use even that description because a
lot of them are just gonna chill by the
shade or close to a pan and they're not
gonna be moving too much in the heat
they can a lot of them don't have sweat
glands and the user mouths to pant to
cool themselves down just as this
lioness is doing so we can tell that
she's very hot so they're not gonna be
moving around creating even more heat
for them so we're making themselves even
more hot and you're just gonna pretty
much stick around in the same spot
throughout the day until they decide
that it is enough and then they're gonna
go and start moving again potentially a
little bit later and as we know the
Lions are pretty full so there's a very
good chance that they'll just stick
around here until the night falls and a
little move out oh hi Megan
oh look sorry I got distracted there cuz
we've got a second lioness going to join
her which is good and she does look like
she's enjoying lying down there in the
shade and perhaps this other one or the
second one that has now approached is
gonna go down for a drink are you or are
you just gonna lie down hmm interesting
you can see those bellies they're
looking happy and full look at that that
is a happy lion that's a lion that's the
well fed hmm there's a third one coming
around alright guys well if you want to
move and then contradict me and then
cross on tours
I'll be very happy to be wrong all right
well this is good when they start
appearing and then we can start counting
them so we've got a lion number for
joining the party
maybe we should count them by their
bellies we can you know roundness number
four coming along coming in it looks
like I summon the member well you know
it's a power of my mind it doesn't
always work I cannot control it it's a
mystery to me when it's gonna work and
when it's not but good the day that they
are going in a done thing there's too
much shade for you there guys I mean
it'll be a lot smarter he just carried
on coming on to twin dams we've got
lovely jackal berry trees that he can go
and lie under all righty are you looking
for watering miss seems like she might
be looking
we wonder where she's gonna go maybe
she's gonna go for a bit of water there
is more shade in there so maybe she's
gonna go there
Philip yes these are the Inca Houma not
all of them we've counted five of them
so we're missing about six of them but
I'm pretty sure that they're gonna be
lying just like this ones are in the
back of the of the tree over there so I
wouldn't be surprised that they some of
them have eaten maybe a little bit more
or they're just like now it's too hard
to move around we've got a nice shady
but here we are going nowhere so it's
very nice of them at least you have come
unto the shade just as we arrived and
then pops this way here because
otherwise they would have been not the
greatest visual now because they are or
they have eaten as much as they have I
don't think they're gonna be hunting to
actively tonight unless they manage to
find a great opportunity in which case
we'll probably take it but I think at
least for one evening they are gonna be
able to enjoy just almost like not not a
busy night in terms of hunting because
the last few days that we've seen them
they've been vain moving all over the
show and they've covered quite a quite a
distance in the last unit I think just
hearing from the stories as to where
Tris and track them from it seems like
they use Juma as a gym the Juma gym as
we call it because they went up and down
and up and down potentially just looking
for different prey species and for an
opportunity to bring something down and
eat it and even though apparently they
had a water buck this morning they
finished it and move off and it gets
complicated when there are so many Lions
um five females a water bucket have been
enough but then of course and you've got
another six of adults that are joining
the party so they will eat a lot and so
it's not too much it's a good meal for
Lions we can see that they've all have
big fat round bellies but perhaps not
enough to keep them in locked in the
same spot for too long we're going to
carry on counting or Lions as they come
from the shade and we'll let you guys
know just how many we see but in the
meantime let's head over to James who's
very eager to say good afternoon to
everyone
and everybody we are going to pounce and
the moment when you can find your Zen
huh I'm today Sunday afternoon as it is
obviously in the favorite in the year
2019 and there DOM and I can you believe
it David it was like just yesterday it
was three BC anymore it's very hot here
everyone not as hot as it has been and
we are driving at this incredibly slow
Miss Daisy speed not because it is
Sunday afternoon and this is the
appropriate speed to drive on a Sunday
which of course teas it is simply
because we are trying desperately to
find sign of Tandy autre Lamba Tandy or
Columba and we have as yet not marriage
and so that's our plan we're sort of the
North middle of the reserve on a road
called hyena Road and as I do like to
tell you of course you can find those
roads on the Google Maps for Zoomer
the more we laid out this everyone's
gonna see exactly one cat but the bush
is stickier and that means that it has
really put under Bush merely Island few
metres off the road it's going to be
very difficult to spot very much like
chellamma for our TV show which is of
course at 6:30 central african time 7:30
east african time and i have absolutely
no idea what time it is wherever you
happen to be as I don't know where you
are
somewhere near tomorrow if you're in
Australia and so many yesterday if
you're in Hawaii I've just had the
following communication from the final
control we are going to go across the
Steve who is sending off his flies
yes well they go the warthogs
I'm sorry gars so didn't mean to chase
you out of the shade
they're about 60 meters from us and as
soon as the camera panned on them they
disappeared I do indeed have flies in a
very nifty fly swatter in the form of a
magic quarry and well we also believe it
is believed if you adorn yourself or
your building or your vehicle with magic
grow branches you're going to bring some
luck so well as James said this SABC
show this evening we would like oh okay
there's a good right there as soon as we
put this branch on we found a kudu two
warthogs fallen parlour and a could
again so I think so far the luck oh he
has a magnificent bull coming here BK
are not that magnificent actually he's a
nice bull he's got a little bit of
growing still to do whose horns quieter
close together look at that the luck is
on our side all of a sudden as he lifts
his tail not in any form of aggression
it's just he is having a poo that as
simple as that you know when you're you
take your dog for a walk what happens
within two minutes of the dog walking
yes indeed we all know he decides I'm
now going to drop a little log on the
floor and that was BK's job to assist me
this morning those of you who missed the
excitement this morning we did not put
it live on TV because we thought well
that's pretty gross but became managed
to bottle a little bit of Okumura sir
dropping this this morning a little bit
of his scat for DNA tests to find out
who exactly his father is and then by
finding that we'll also be able to find
out who in fact he is the father of
which is very exciting stuff cuckoo
Maury this is the area a little bit
further from here that we found them
found him yesterday and I don't think
these could have got too much to worry
especially the mail from a big male
leopard could who generally are stick
that was BBK made a very funny noise on
the back with his foot it sound like a
leopard roaring behind me it wasn't
but but look at how the CUDA walks one
foot steps exactly where the other one
was before typical of the Trager loafers
and the spiral horned families but the
Carew
looks very awkward Arts in the open
doesn't it stood out quite well there
and as soon as it goes into the thickets
it really does blend in so it is a
thicket specialist or sort of semi
woodland specialist and that is where
they where they reside and I'm thinking
that these two plus the impalas and the
warthogs we had a little while ago have
come from a red dam in the West to have
a drink and they are slowly making their
way back this being at the time of day
when it is the hottest and well the
chances of lions being willing or active
enough to try and catch them is quite
limited so although a lot of energy
expended to walk to the watering hole
there is less opportunity for predators
to be active in the heat to try and
catch them so there's a sort of a payoff
there but see how well the crew has just
disappeared into the shade and that's
probably where they're going to spend
the rest of the afternoon after getting
a lot of water in the belly it's time to
go and feed on the juicy delicious
leaves nor maybe with the water in his
belly he'll now decide to do a little
bit of ruminating possibly on a whole
lot of leaves
he has already ingested well we're going
to leave this beautiful kudu hidden
behind a quarry bush and a buffalo thorn
and we're going to continue on seeing
what we might be able to find but in the
meantime while we try and get ourselves
a such lovely breeze coming around now
that's wonderful
we're going to blow you all the way back
up to the mass M R with David in search
of the sausage tree prize well it's very
interesting just to let you know that
the kudu we do not have any crews in the
Mara
I'd say further north of Kenya or
further north of the Equator
we got crews and we got two types of
kudos unlike in Juma or like in South
Africa we got what we call the greater
kudu and a lesser kuru and I've always
wondered why we don't have the kudos of
the Mara and my only quick thinking
would be we do not have the right
habitat to have the kudos in the Mara
either one the elevation is too high too
it could be too cold for them and maybe
the type of diet we have here could not
be very good or palatable to their kudos
so the kudos are more of dry areas or
what I'll call a semi arid semi-arid
habitats so we do not have any crews in
the Mara I'm trying to think of what
animal that could be closed to the Kudus
here and I don't see any because when
you look at the Spiro Hans you know of
the mayors of the Cooter's and I I'm
trying to remember which one could be
similar to the kudos little shadow you'd
like to know whether we get white rhinos
in the Mara good question but no we do
not get white rhinos in the Mara the
Mara and I would say Kenya as a country
we have always had the black rhinos and
we got areas in Kenya where we got white
rhinos but I'll tell you the oil traders
were introduced here in Kenya they're
not native to Kenya so all the Rhinos we
got in Namara or black rhinos which are
indigenous to this particular area and
even after the introduction of the white
rhinos in Kenya they did very well
we now got some national parks that you
call centuries like this one called Lake
Nakuru
and I think they got over 50 avoid
trainers there and they blended in and
they did very well
so you've been seeing the numbers
growing steadily along the years
so once the oil here the Barra we also
end up seeing ray knows when you're
lucky so I have now officially got to my
destination which was the area or the
area where normally the sausage trip
ride stays around or stick around and
yesterday was rather frustrated when I
came here and I did not see any one of
them and three days earlier they had a
buffalo kill so went back to the kill
I did not see even a single hyena there
are no traces of where they want they
went and unlike Juma where you can
always follow trucks you know on the
road on the ground in the bara it's
practically impossible to do that even
during the dry times or dry seasons like
now I mean the grass is everywhere and
will always end up with some bare ground
like what you see ahead of me
simply because we keep passing here this
is a road for drink embrace but it's
almost impossible difficult as the
Franklin flying out there it's almost
impossible to say a hike and see some
tracks here so let me just follow them
is two very tough will always come and
just toppika and get your Bibles and
just scan across the grass or if you're
very lucky you're driving along the road
and a cut could be very close to the
road
bridge the bridge you asking about the
Euler errors and the cab now the last he
had was two days ago and the female in
the order of pride is doing very well
with hard to cabs and I'll tell you
apparently I have a passion for lions
and I don't know how to explain this it
becomes difficult if you get bonded to a
particular prize and then you hear the
hola laurels you like all right you're
doing fine you hear of another pride
like the Salt Lick pride they are doing
fine and you won't even bother but this
particular pride here is I'm talking
about I have been coming here every day
let's come in tomorrow so I cannot tell
you you know how big the cabs are or
will they have any huge but the last
updates I got of that female of the oil
price is that they are doing fine maybe
tomorrow next week the drives I might go
in that particular area and see the
progress firsthand but at the meantime I
just wanted to stick around and follow
this particular pride I'm sure you know
this one female here that gave birth
called the kink tale and she has not
shown as her cubs she has I know that
she I would say she has not even
introduced the Cubs to the main prize
and my guess is either they are still
too young and because he is the oldest
female in this particular pride she's a
I would say very experienced
she's very careful and she doesn't want
to commit her cubs expose them to any
danger because anything from zero to
three months lion capsule is very
vulnerable and anything would easily go
wrong
I'm sure I will get to my pride of lions
because Ali is very proud she already
got so they look home as a guests well I
mean we can't really claim all that
credit for this particular sighting it's
very hard for the Lions to be moving out
and about right now you can see that's
hiding in the long grass belly-up
panting very quickly it's a good day to
be a lion I mean in the shade the
temperature I would imagine is a lot
better than out here in the in the heat
of the day or elsewhere there is no
shade so you can see they've all
strategically placed themselves in
different parts just to try and stay
away and stay away from the heat of
course they're not all lying around you
know they've somewhat gathered and
they're all lying around different
bushes but we have counted 11 different
ones so we can test the power we can
really firm that the ink the entire in
consumer pride is here with us today
which is pretty good so just hoping that
they're gonna come unto the property or
at least out of the bushes so that they
can be stars on tonight's show that will
be pretty good and if not well you know
it's always lovely to see them and it's
the reason why we do this is the job
that we do we love having the Lions
around love seeing what they get off to
it seems like the last lioness is now
coming and will pretty much walk the
same path and she's going straight as to
where the rest of the family was Rosalyn
they've got a few different strategies
to survive the heats the lion so one or
a very common one is exactly what
they're doing right now is not to move
in the heat of the day or not to move
during the day and they'll just lie
under a tree you and or in the shade
where it's a few degrees much cooler
than what it is outside and about
everywhere where we've been which is
maybe so let me just try to move back
see if this lioness is gonna come
because I can't see her now she's in
behind the one tree so let me just move
around for one second so that is one
strategy that they've got and then of
course they pant often to try and cool
themselves down by trying to evaporate
some of the moisture that they collect
in their mouth with in their nostrils
and so on so those are I would say are
mostly the two main things and they're
of course by instinct very clever and
they know not to work themselves to
harder started running or do too much
when it's really hot because that can of
course test their body and their limits
and then just put them in a in a very
bad condition is they can also get
heatstroke very much in the sense or in
the way that a domestic dog or a cat can
do you wouldn't really lock them in in a
place where it's hot kids and if they've
got no shade or watery they started
running around like crazy during the
heat of the day chances are that
something is not gonna go down too well
for them hmm somebody had a nice meal
they're always so funny with a big fed
stomachs once they manage to eat a lot
now they go like we said they were
scattered in all the different areas so
very likely in the little in the next
little while they're all gonna plug
their heads go on to the bottom go and
lie down
a little bit you are them again boy huh
okay always referring to you as a she
I'm so sorry unfortunately with the
glare and the distance and I seem to
have misplaced my binoculars today I
cannot see everything to the detail but
that extra fur underneath the chin now
that it laid sideways and definitely
signal that it's actually a male lion or
a young male lion and not a female good
there's seems like they're all around
here I think we're gonna leave them and
then come back a little bit later in the
hopes that they're gonna be more active
in the meantime let's go to Steve and I
think the heat has finally gotten to him
thanks Ali I would feel very lost if I'd
lost my binoculars at the part of me but
if you can't find shade folks you need
to make your own here's a little
Senegal Lapwing just over here he's
enjoying some shade oh it's moving now
don't move very nice little Lapwing the
synagogue not commonly seen actually in
the in many areas I've been uh I need
two locations I've ever worked I found
them quite easy to identify we talked
about birds and identify birds and you
can see they've got very long legs and
very upright sort of standing posture
and if you go to the lapwings in the
book they all have that same sort of
look that very big I generally occurring
in sort of open landscapes and I the
blacksmith Lapwing obviously being the
black and white variation and they occur
in and around water and the Senegal at
wing very very common on sort of over
grazed and sort of disturbed areas where
they seem to find their preference the
other one the crown that we much easy to
identify them the synagogue's got that
very nice sort of cap on the head and
they like to be on golf courses as well
as open areas so very easy to identify
the lapwings for me there's another one
called the wattle Lapwing and let me ask
you if you could understand what that
would be and yes indeed got funny little
wattles on the face
and while these birds walk around and
their feed on all sorts of insects on
the ground might feed on small seeds as
well but primarily insect eaters and
they've lost their back toe most
ground-dwelling birds not all of them
but most ground-dwelling birds have lost
the the back toe like david's ostrich
they've reduced the toes altogether to
fuse to in the front and have a second
one on the side for balance and that's
all about just surface area really on
the ground thick thick knees and courses
and lapwings most wading birds have all
lost as a toe on their foot they reduced
it to three toes just for walking
not for perching they don't
perch at all that's where the
passerines or the three-toed birds that
have toes on the same level they need
that back toe so that can stay in the
bush free from predators at night
whereas these guards will just sort of
bed down right where they are on the
ground the second one behind it
see the white belly a little bit of a
white forehead as well and very very
nice to see there you can see the foots
at the back there
just the three toes chatter ah you said
something about lap wings
I'm not sure what you said they're a
Marten but check my said something about
talking about lapwings oh this is a very
nice left wing to see it's one of the
lapwings most people don't get to see
yes indeed Sedna I was hiding as a bush
in it they want to come and stand in my
shade yeah I am a talking bush and
that's why I'm able to get so much
closer to these birds than I would
normally well they're seeking out shade
that is very hot folks and out well the
birds have a benefits over us in that
their installation or their feathers
repel most of the sunlight but
unfortunately once they reach a certain
limit of heat then they get very very
hot they don't have the same ability to
cool down that we have so when you have
the up wings and the like like this
standing in the shade then you know it
is a warm afternoon any feathers are
designed to actually reflect light so
that's many of the black birds that you
see the iridescent the birds they almost
reflect the heat completely and they can
stand or sit in the Sun quite a sort of
free of overheating your notes are set
with the vultures and lots of birds of
prey they don't really have anywhere to
go
except for sitting in the tree and just
waiting they can't just pop down onto
the ground and go into the shade like
these lapwings do there we go there's
three of them now all of a sudden
constantly being vigilant they are even
though it's so hot very vigilant but if
they just sit down
it's amazing how quickly they can blend
in to the short grass and just disappear
okay well are we going to move on head
on down to our boundary road make a turn
past where the hyena den we found this
morning is locates it I don't think
there's going to be too much activity
for now but we're going to go have a
look anyway let's go back up to the Mara
in the meantime with David
we'll keep moving on it's cuz it's by
moving that things will happen not
staying in one same place and that's
exactly what I was doing I have been
moving and I'm also moving I'm not
stopping until I get myself some reward
of some kind just like Ali who got the
Lions me and Steve have to move on to
get cuts over own well I'm saying that
is because I have come back to the very
first place I saw pink tail and where'd
think she gave birth to but ideally that
that doesn't mean she's still there
because what would happen is she will
need to keep changing her location every
now and then so let me see this little
bee eater vanish watch you can get it
it's a small little thing there I'm sure
I gonna be tough
well sure I know your magical when it
comes to cover this little bee eater
there and right behind that be something
yes if you go there nice Jimmy well done
keep going just see there to get right
I just flew oh yeah that's it
it'll be you two there that I can see it
now
yeah excellent
very good oops back this imposition
flying coming back so behind that
Villita that is the very fast Den but
kink tail dropped
Cubs and it's so good at least for me at
least you see a bead in an area I've
been to three times not seeing anything
but right behind those tickets is where
Kingston Kingston is one of the females
in the trip right and that's be eita
every good customer you're worried are
you asking about the missing Cubs for me
tea now nothing to worry about because
the very first time is for one missing
and that's so how it's three cubs and
three days ago
I saw how it's two instead of even three
and the numbers for coming down but when
I saw how is to kink Televi was not
there and my own gods toward me chances
are King still stayed back with Metis
other two cups so for now there's
nothing to worry and I'm sure you know
lionesses will always just suck off each
other's caps without any discrimination
so King tell having her own Cubs and
having Cubs you know of meaty should not
have been a problem that's what I'm
crossing my fingers for but I can tell
you between today or tomorrow the day
after we should didn't be knowing
exactly how things look you remember are
we at one point meet he had lost one cub
you know lost in quotes because after a
few days you know the kaabah surfaced
and was able to rejoin the pride so even
this particular time nothing very big to
worry and in that particular team move
the kaabah had fallen in the ditch and I
think MIT you will not bring it out
so the beater they're not all of them
you know we'll eat bees as the name
suggests they eat insects that we're
flying
beaters let's see what bad stevie is
talking about yes well welcome back we
have found ourselves a cuckoo that is
trying too hard in the shade as well on
the edge of a branch of that marula tree
that's been sitting with its mouth it's
still got its mouth wide open trying to
cool down you can see there's a little
bit of a breeze there from the wind and
that's as beautiful spots a little bit
of elevation for the cuckoo and the wind
blowing over the the lips or should I
say the wet tongue is what helps birds
to cool down that is their cooling
system two term called gala fluttering
now I can't tell you for certain which
cuckoo it is it's either the common
cuckoo or the African cuckoo they've
both got a yellow eye and they've both
got a yellow beak just the degree of
yellowness on the beak is the the key
really there's more yellow at the base
on the the African then on the common
cuckoo but the cold is often what you go
by the African pop and who doesn't forty
very chance that you it is African and
I'll play so that you know that's a very
very typical sort of cuckoo call are you
ready for it
[Music]
nikinike can you hear that he's saying
cuckoo very simple like like the cuckoo
clock really you want to know if this
bird occurs in Japan well I'm not aware
of it occurring in Japan they basically
are migrants in Africa so I don't know
what cuckoos you get over the pad I'm
really not sure but this bird goes up
sort of into sort of a bit of central
Africa and then comes all the way back
down here again it doesn't go into
Europe where the common cuckoo does
indeed go all the way to Europe this one
comes down Spain Brechin roots of birds
are not people of continent so a bird to
go from from Africa over to America I'm
from Asia way down but there follow the
continent I'm not sure what Japan is
like whether the ocean is a bit too far
for birds to get across but that is out
of my depth I'm afraid for now but it's
possible you get cuckoos in Japan really
is but I absolutely have no deep
specialist that's these birds come all
the way down here for most of the
cuckoos or pretty much all the cuckoos
they've come all the way down to feed on
the blooms of caterpillars hatch on many
of the trees out yet and they are
obviously the larvae which then form the
butterflies and so not only are they an
important food source they D foliate
leaves of treat and so they turn into
butterflies which then are very
important pollinators for thousands of
the plants that we found around here
just be what around if it is indeed the
African cuckoo I'm just going to assume
it is because they're a little bit more
commonly seen and then um although the
name might but I spam ape the
but you not too sure what I mean by
parasitize will basically lay their eggs
in a host species nest and then leave
requiring no parental care they lay lots
of eggs that cause a bit of havoc with
the host species itself and the host
itself then raises those chicks to
adulthood and there's many strategies
that the the cuckoos employ some of them
will remove the egg and then lay an egg
down because somehow birds are able to
count the female comes back and notice
whether there's three eggs versus four
so if they just lay a fourth egg there's
a very good chance that they will just
kick it out so some cookies will move
the egg other cuckoos when they're hatch
the chick will kill all of the chicks in
the nest and some of them will actually
be reared with the chicks themselves
getting much bigger than their doom and
aren't competing them all together so
it's very funny when you see a fork self
younger feeding a bird that's almost
twice its size
well anyway from our cuckoo in the shade
we're gonna try on some more shade let's
go up to James who's up in the north
east of the property around before Sudan
yes indeed we have got a gray her own
sitting at befalls hook damn her own is
not wiped it's beak after it's sunday
lunch you can see there it is Gouda
fluttering up a storm in other words
it's trying to cool down but also it's
got its lunch stuck on in its beak
unfortunate now I think that's the least
attractive bird that we have here not
that it's an unattractive bird
necessarily but we have a flamingo over
to the right-hand side you see the
flamingos David with a red beak yellow
beak sorry that flamingos now obviously
that's not a flamingo Sierra will Stoke
but if it turns its back you can see his
activate punk
now Ollie and I were here yesterday and
we were talking about these things with
you and amongst each other and you have
a very nice explanation which I actually
didn't know about for why it is or what
the differences are in the feeding
behavior of the yellow-billed stork aka
flamingo and the spoon bell which has
just talked to the left there and I
suppose I probably could have read about
this but I certainly hadn't all he
managed to find a dead spoon until one
day he didn't collect it as they say in
scientific terms in other words he
didn't shoot it out of the sky and then
examine it he did they found one when he
was at the tracker Academy at LAN Losey
and they opened its beak up obviously
and it is apparently like sandpaper and
what that sandpapery spoon shaped beak
allows them to do is catch slippery fish
and frogs tadpoles I suppose as well but
largely fish in most areas is what they
eat and it allows them to catch those
fish with that sound very beak now
you'll find that whoa here comes the
Heron you'll find what they do is that
they feed in a much more aggressive
fashion than the stork will the stalk
walks very slowly through the water like
a heron does with its beak down and if
it senses the slightest movement on its
feet or near its beak it will quickly
snap down and that is its strategy
whereas the the spoonball sort of
disturbs the mud and tries to get things
to flush out of the way and then it will
snap shut on them and because it's got
that sound papery beak it'll manage to
hold them so that is the story there now
we have found some tracks Tandy and
Colombo which is excellent news well
actually just clamber she was coming
towards this waterhole we haven't
managed to see her here and so we're
going to continue our search for her
pretty soon then of course the great
scuba Steve and his lady
scuba let's hope you hold on to your
lady
until the 14th of this month of course
Jemma no birds don't sweat birds
Goulart flutter or pent which is what
that mm harren was doing sorry the game
drive radios going to result in the
explosion of my brain
okay I've turned it off not and what
they've got this pouch in their throats
that they flap up and down and it's
moist and so through evaporative cooling
they're managed to cool the blood that
is going over that pouch it sounds a
little bit like panting in a dog and
that's how they cool themselves but they
can't switch those feathers are
tremendously good insulators though as
well so it'll take a lot longer for them
to get hot then it would for you and I
to get hot but once they do get hot then
they'll very hot they of course swim a
lot to birds they like to get in the
water and swim and the case of the spoon
bulls they seem to be having a Sunday
afternoon nap you see that David they've
all gone to sleep they put their spoons
behind their wings and they're having a
nap my mother would thoroughly approve
except it's now 5:00 o'clock which means
probably time for tea yes and scones
wouldn't be nice if we had some tea and
cream scones hey I think it'd be
delicious tea tea and cream scones at
the hook damn
that way wonderful just thick cream and
little dollop of strawberry jam nice
things gone some hot Earl Grey or normal
tea either will do no not going to
happen is it David no matter how much
how will it to heaven
alright let's carry on began to try and
continue to find a time before the TV
show and for you of course we have an
hour left with you
well most agree of course will be with
us for the TV show anyway
I'm going to do a little turnaround here
and there we'll go back to the way we
came and see what we can come up with
apparently a number of you saying you're
going to go and buy some scones now you
mustn't do that because they'll almost
certainly be disgusting you must make
them they're very easy to make my mother
always said first thing she learned to
make and her mother wouldn't know she
was a domestic science teacher believe
it or not my mother's mother my
grandmother and scones you can make very
easily
butter butter flour don't use margarine
please whatever you do butter flour a
little bit of baking powder tiny a
little bit of sugar a pinch of salt in
the oven and you'll have a lovely
Fluffy's gone whatever you do don't yell
by one because some cretinous company
will have put all sorts of preservatives
and things in them so that they don't
actually have to put food in the food
that you buy I mean why would you have
food in the food that you buy so rather
make them and whip the cream yourself
don't get it out of can because again
you know all sorts of nonsense in that
step alright let's go back to the valve
now I don't know where he is but he is
with a high you know it sounds very
exciting indeed middle welcome back
everybody we just had a Kingfisher
woodland King fit there here it's coming
down to probably wet himself with this
little pen just over here and he just
she's trying to think whether it's a
good idea because well in the pad on
this side of the pan that we spotted was
a spotted hyena I'm not sure who and
there we go bottom of the screen and
it's just off to our 10 side about 20
meters or so is the den sites that we
located this morning or should we say
woody helps us to locate this morning
and I am super jealous of this hyena
sitting in this little bath of water
because it looks very very cool doesn't
it does that be K mmm a little bit
envious of this I you know I'm not sure
who'd is if it turns left yet I might
see but I don't know very hard to
identify them when they're lying flat
like this and the Kingfisher is still
sitting there trying to think whether
the hyenas dangerous enough to flop down
in the water and have a little bit of a
bath that's another way Birds cool down
they bath but they will flap down into
the water wet themselves a very quick
sort of dip enough sooo not waterlogged
their feathers so that they drown enough
just to get them wet and then they go
sits on a branch like that cleaning
themselves moving their water through
the feathers and then me if need be they
were preen once again getting all the
oil refreshed on the feathers and
zipping all of their flight feathers
to where there were in sort of heat
times of the day when activity is very
low because of the heat birds will often
spend a lot of time in the shade doing
just that sort of a fixing and redoing
all of their feathers Riven do you hope
it's cool okay well it's the heads up
now it's deaf ear not Corki cork is the
only one I'm very confident at
identifying straight away but to the
left ear there does not have the knotch
but if you are not watching this morning
folks we followed her koumori who led us
straight to the dead site and he
actually spotted some of the Cubs which
then disappeared into the ground I
didn't see them but Rickson was here
with us and he was like hiding at a
hyena den and Okumura was looking very
intently at the hole and out of nowhere
the matriarch orc he came storming in
and she chased the hook away isn't she
such a good mum and then we went through
a raging debate about who would win in a
battle Corki or who Komori maybe we
should do an afternoon debate on that as
well what do you all think hashtag a
safari live who would win in a
one-on-one fight
coo coo moody or the matriarch Corki
it's into your answers let's see what
you think
and I've got my opinions of course
ah head looks just way too comfortable
way too comfortable there he not way too
comfortable ah look at that's just
getting more and more comfortable that's
not fair
that's not fair is it BK this is the
afternoon you wish you were sipping cool
kool-aid by the swimming pool you know I
was in Mozambique last week in the way
there was similar to this but there was
a swimming pool at the place I stayed at
and we were on the beach so it was a
very easy to keep cool you just said
maybe a minute or two of being hot and
then you were cool again and then it was
just a constant process of bathing
oneself is one of the things we need to
come up with a solution for keeping
ourselves cool I have forgotten my spray
bottle today I normally had a spray
bottle with cool water but I normally
spray myself enjoy you reckon
hands down or should we say paws down
Corky for the wind okay very interesting
Corky for the win definitely when it
comes to being around the den site I
mean okie will tolerate nothing since
her lion encounter at the old den site
any leopard coming nearby is going to
catch her breath
I mean to survive a lion mauling means
you must be one tough cookie I don't
know if any of you watched the show when
I was up in the Mara we actually did a
special broadcast as well when we found
we were with the sausage tree pride we
were with five lioness that were walking
and suddenly this sort of injured hyena
came into shot and well the lioness has
decided that this is fun and all five of
them gave it a proper proper hammering
and the hyena managed to get away with a
whole lot of squeals and shots and
managed to bite when the lioness has on
the nose which obviously probably led
that lioness to to think twice it was
quite a small hyena you would have
thought five Lions would easily have
killed it but incredible INE was walking
on its two front sort of feet as if the
poles are broken and somehow as soon as
the Lions thought it's a chase that it
managed
muster up the strength to run at full
speed but obviously a hyena over short
distance is no match for a lioness and
they caught it as we went laughs in that
broadcast and well it ended quite well I
suppose for the hyena we didn't see it
afterwards but it seemed to get away and
we know these animals are extremely
resilient and they get mauled all the
time they fight each other all the time
and somehow they just come out the other
side with just a few scratches and
scrapes well talking about the wide open
expanses of the Mara and the sausage
tree pride no one knows them better than
David Guiteau very good to be there I
took of hyenas and lions and all their
dynamics but I've seen like here we are
in the Mara if there's any confrontation
between hyenas and lions in general the
hyenas will always win as much as of
course it depends on you know the
numbers of course the numbers make a
very big difference of course eve like
many lions again it's one or two hyenas
definitely the Lions will win but in
general we get very big plants in the
Mara of highness there's one especially
called the north one which has like 7080
hyenas you can imagine and that's a very
huge number by any standard and they
have been known to deal with any pride
of lions wherever they find them
especially if they know they gotta kill
and I'm sure you know how sensitive
hyenas are they got very sharp hearing
and as soon as they can pick crunching
of bones somewhere by lions it doesn't
take long before they get there and what
they'll do they'll start whooping and
they'll send the lead you know the
leader highness especially the females
to go and survey whether they see it in
or out guess a lot of a measely up from
the king
and then they're going to call the
others and then they go hoping that you
see them coming in twos then Falls that
is see that a number of like ten as the
liens continue eating you'll notice they
start interpreting them by making
themselves look big they cook up the
tails the numbers swell and they hope
they even get more louder and the Lions
gets irritated and ideally they just
leave the kill and move on anyhow
because of the lions of their the Lions
the hyenas of the Mara and trying to
find out where these lions would be and
because of the heat of the day I'm
imagining because they got the Cubs they
are all under some shades hiding and I
think Steve is getting lucky with hyenas
hyenas highness
we are indeed David you should try and
employ the magic quarry branch on the
handers proved to be very very fortunate
for us this afternoon and well now we
have turned around we left that one
hyena just there by the pool and we
turned the corner only 30 meters of soap
to find who I believe I could be
completely wrong to be pretty with her
bottom inside the termite mound this is
where Rickson sought the young pups or
cubs should I say pop down at the
approach of hooker moody this morning
and it's definite Corky because Corky's
got a notch in her left yeah so please
those of you out there if you can tell
me if this is pretty I'd love to know
I'm trying to be an open my my what you
call it yes it's working very good
my phone is working I was in a very bad
signal area so I might be able to get
these images art to be able to make sure
I know who I'm looking at but without
looking at the body patterning and the
spots on the side it's very difficult to
identify these hyenas but we know that
both pretty and Corky had had Cubs so
it's possible that because her bottom is
in there and that she is one of the
mothers okay
and she could have very nice nope that's
definitely not pretty who sits in there
I'm going to have to go through all of
them to find up to exactly we are
looking at pretties also got a bit of a
notch in her ear which makes it a little
bit tricky yes joy thanks joy I've just
noticed that on my app that she's got
another she's also got a notch on her
left ear but at different place to Corky
and joy reckons it might be hot okay joy
thanks for that time we'd have a look
and see I really need to put some effort
in over the next little while to find
out who these actually are because well
there's very tricky for me
hyenas I need to really put a lot of
time in here but Jamie has put
a lot of effort into the the app were
not the app but our our database so it
is important for us to get involved and
to find out who's who and what's going
on but I'll have a look for Hart have
found an image for you let me have a
look and see if it appears to be her
she's a very pretty high unit no obvious
scars on the face ears are in very good
condition but I noticed when I was out
with Lauren that one day we were using
her ID kit that day and that lines and
spots along the body seemed to be the
best way to identify them and
unfortunately for now she's lying flat
but maybe we'll be lucky and the
youngsters will pop out but for now I
think the hyenas have been watching or
listening to me over the state is most
certainly I ena thank you so much for
your observations it is definitely a
hyena and there's a termite mound and I
think the I ena have been listening to
my stories since I got back from
Mozambique because they've got their own
pool just here mere metres away from
their home because in the heat there's
nothing nicer than a swimming pool close
by
and while these hyenas have taken
advantage of that they don't have to
walk very far to drink and to cool down
and then the other den sites have always
happened to walk a little bit further
but obviously walking distance for I
mean it is really nothing not too much
effort but right now it's very very easy
and you can see this one's even lying in
the shade
okay so Hart doesn't have any Nixle
isn't it is she also doesn't have any
notes to sports cars my face so this
could be there's no scars at all she's
got all sorts of interesting markings on
her side though she's got a music like
note on the one yeah look the one on her
brother gets a name from the science
that is a sideways question mark of
spots beneath so I've got a nice little
image here that if she decides to step
I'll be able to have a look
but right now
very hard to fire anyway we'll spend
time here hopefully the youngsters will
come out BK and I've managed to find a
beautiful shady spot so we're quite
happy to stay here for the time being
and while we do that let's go over to
Elly and see exactly what she's up to
well yes lucky the wedding has come down
it almost feels like that pre rain wind
or the wind that's gonna build a cloud
cloud build up of course that's not the
best choice of words but it feels like
it might just cool down and hopefully
we'll get some rain at some point
because it's been very hot today
seems like Steve scooped the opportunity
to go and check the the hyena den which
is good suppose very nice to see the
little ones always wonderful and I feel
sorry for Jamie she was so so keen to
try and find them but Murphy's Law as it
would happen the person that wants to
see them the most or that's put in the
most effort it's the person that's gonna
have to you
wait a little bit longer to be able to
see them I suppose I shall enjoy her
reward and no doubt she'll spend a lot
of time with there she'll be very happy
to have that post it seems like the
little hyena Cubs are coming out and
about so let's go and say hi
well everybody look at who has popped
its head out of the den welcome to the
newest members or member of the Juma
clan just kind of speak a bit softer
never heard my voice before now Steph
you know clonk clonk has already gone
past the stage of dark coloration and
maybe this individual I you know has had
some Cubs of her own that would be super
super awsome it's back at the hole now
that's putting its head out again BK BK
to the right there we go
here she comes here it comes it's the
early stages the first two months or so
three months two months the first month
and a half Estill completely dark like
this I don't know when last any of us
have seen this clan so we wouldn't know
of any new members and if she suckles
and there's definitely mum because i
enas do not share suckling duties like
hi like limpet like lions do it is mum
or nothing very inquisitive a little bit
of shade there behind the little bush
aren't you a cute little why not this is
very special
how much too much fur or skin on the top
of the head om i think it's a little bit
too hot for now for them to be playful
but in the next half hour maybe 45
minutes as possible they might be a
little bit more active and they might
come out and explore maybe come and play
with a stick or two isn't that just so
precious
let's go and suckle it mummy there's a
very precious everybody and we're right
on the boundary which is on the northern
side of the fire break road so 30 40
metres from Gallery main itself which is
a southern boundary with little Gary in
Hoffman's and like I said it is Okamura
led us to this day inside this morning
and maybe he spotted this little one I
don't know I have
seen any other youngsters near the
answers are also and they're grown quite
a bit I'm sure since last we saw them
they're probably all just full of spots
and apparently images saw another one
pop up behind to is very common in high
Heena breeding and to youngsters that
must be mum it way too playful with
someone who's not your mum that's deaf
master philippi mum there we go are you
going to go for the Nepal yes it's just
too much skin on the head can you see
that and I can't imagine what's going on
in the nose that little gangster is
probably smelling all sorts of things -
cadet hello welcome to the world little
one I wonder if it was in fact born on
June up we don't know how long the Sun
in sight has been active for James is
quite certain that the hyenas have been
dragging carcasses south of the boundary
so it's likely to again but it's
possible there might even be two we
don't know we don't spend any time down
there which is the problem it's a little
bit of digging going on I think BK
there's lots of dust coming out of the
hole someone's digging it might be some
play happening inside so the hyena mum
can dig into the term up man to make the
cavity and then the youngsters can
actually dig in a little bit more to
make sort of a smaller little alcove
where they can hide away because as
we've seen the likes of ting Ghana can
go straight inside a termite mound like
this and still manage to turn around so
it is a cavernous sort of drop in there
and we've even had James Hendry going
inside of its hermit mound when he lost
Ronald the rover so there's all sorts of
things going on it Kathy from our you
said they're looking a little bit brown
headed well I think that's from the dust
it's very dusty in there and it's very
likely that this den site has been newly
newly dug not too long ago so
I saw a redheaded redheaded I'm sure
that's got to do with the dust as well
the brown well the dark chocolate brown
of the body mixed together with the sort
of pale sand probably gives it a little
bit of that ready to sort of shimmer but
a lot of that's also got to do with the
light but I assure you if we happen to
take it and dunk it in the pool just off
to the right Soviet it would come out
rather dark indeed well it's mum is not
bothered at all by our presence JW they
don't keep snakes art other than eating
them the only way to keep a snake out is
to completely close something even our
rooms snakes can potentially come
underneath doors if you have a little
gap snakes have an ability to get into
the smallest of areas so there's nothing
to keep a snake out and pythons are well
known to live inside of termite mounds
and there's documents commentary's years
ago of pythons actually killing and
ingesting baby
leopards a very sad story it is part of
what happens Archer though so you're
never completely safe from anything in a
big rock python it really has the
ability to get into areas that other
predators can't that is traumatic that
documentary went and the the Python
ingests at the cub and apparently the
female waited for the Python to come out
of wherever it had been and then she
killed it and then emerged or re-emerged
the cub out of its belly but the kaabah
was dead
very very sad either from constricting
or from suffocation or not breathing
with inside the body cavity of the
Python so pythons are the means you know
they do what they do when there's even
cases in other parts of the world of
small humans being ingested by large
large snakes so that's important not to
fall asleep Bush and always have an eye
or a friend out to watch you well as
nice as it sounds we would love to have
the Sun setting to cool
thing down it seems like David is
watching her the Setting Sun very well
done Vova - the sports are Heinicke
bender that makes me now even work
harder to look for the Cubs have been
looking for here but haven't seen as yet
hopefully is not going to be another
frustrating afternoon like yesterday
because yesterday was here for couple of
hours and I saw nothing and I was just
trying to get my statistics yesterday
and I said out of every ten times I have
come here there's only two times I'll
miss them so I'm counting yesterday and
if that is what it will be then this
will be the second of the ten times
there from tomorrow are searching them
every other day so I have looked in
every possible place because what I'm
putting in consideration is the edge of
the cabs of meaty one of the females
there and of course the cabs of King
cell which those are the tiniest and the
newest and I wouldn't imagine them going
are very long distance what I'm guessing
well we were hoping to find Columbus
somewhere around here we had squirrels
alarming close to the pan where she was
left yesterday so we thought we'd come
in and have a look-see maybe we got
lucky but so far it seems like not too
much luck we haven't been able to
probably stop the squirrel or does this
girl have stopped calling now and then
of course we haven't actually found the
left leg so that makes it a little bit
tricky we're just hoping that she's
gonna be around here coz there were no
tracks for her oncoming out on the road
at least not from this morning so
chances are that she's still in here
somewhere
seems like Steve has managed to get
another view of the cub so we'll send
you guys across while we carry on
looking for some more spots well on the
other side of the tumor but now look at
who we found there's all sorts going on
here I'm thinking this might be plunk
I'm not sure everybody then I mean it
with a big notch in the left ear I think
that is Corky that is Corky and Corky
has got the one youngster called plunk
who last time we saw him he was a very
very dark in color and the only way to
really be sure who's puppet or whose cub
is who is when their sucker like that
isn't that the most affectionate little
cuddle that's happening there and just
on the other side of the termite mounds
from when we were that first tiny near
that who was before who we thinking
might be hot came around to say hello
there was a bit of activity that went on
and then we found these two sitting here
so aren't we just very fortunate today
thank you
Gauri branches for the lack thing you
have brought for us we have surely
missed spending time with Tina's you
only really noticed when you don't get
them Thank You Monique for confirming
that it's Corky this is definitely the
hyena that came out this morning
plug plugs practically on his back this
is the one that came out this morning
and rushed koumori and chased him
sending him off into the distance
because well we know that pretty she's
also got a bit of a kink in her yeah
it's a little bit more to the right of
Corky's kink and she had to youngster to
a bigger than plunk at the moment but
last time I saw them they looked like a
plank does now and he he looks like they
do so I'm sure they are much bigger in
size incredible how they are growing and
still suckling of course because I
Heenan will suckle for up to a year one
of the longest sort of suckling mammals
for their size due to the enormous
amount of bone in side the diet of the
hyena laps and to provide food for them
will milk them for a lot longer and so
the Cubs will stay around the den until
at least a year before venturing out
into the wilderness to become a fully
fledged scavenger or hunter and try it
then you need to be big enough to deal
with here comes one on the right but see
if there's going to be some activity
here we go
so everybody now we can see this
individual standing quite nicely I'm
going to see if I can see there's
interesting spots on the side but they
are rather plain in fact I can't really
see oh hello there's an ass you want you
think I'm interesting do you we're gonna
get far phone out and see if I could see
recognize any sort of markings on the
body as Corky's looking way too
comfortable there and Corky's bottom is
a very wet I think she was in the pool a
while ago while these two well while
this one has been sitting around the the
den site with the young step so there's
at least three adults in the area with
at least two little ones which well is
very special and they've been here for
we don't know how long I know I've been
seeing lots of trap
in the area that the day before Jamie
Patterson went on leave he was quite
adamant to try and go and find the den
site but as it can be a difficult task I
have tracked hyenas before for hours and
hours and their tracks just go
everywhere they managed to cover
enormous areas they're not the
wonderings ever searched a food for they
ever-growing bellies and to provide the
milk for their never-ceasing me never
ceasing Cubs is that why James called it
plunk because of its ability to just lie
upside down and plunk itself down on the
ground it is ridiculous it is ridiculous
em up but they look at the affection
coming from mum there he is such a good
mum we saw you chase off behind you know
we did there we go a little bit of
licking of the anal gland first thing
this thing to do in the morning for ye
neza stood in the a log land it's quite
a revolting thought sigh I know that in
with dogs many people you take them to
the vets to get their anal gland sort of
pushed out because most books don't
paste like they probably should and so
you're able to go and get the the anal
gland avoided and dogs I think it must
be the most revolting smell on the
planet but does exactly what it does I
don't know she's looking very
comfortable she's looking comfortable
plunks not looking very comfortable but
she couldn't have a care in the world
she's seen off of the interloper who
Komori she is seeing to her little cub
and I doubt she'll be art on the prowl
once again as the shade or the Sun sets
she's on the nice side and the eastern
facing side of the mound with where
she's been doing some digging and there
is the Sun on that side so she's on the
eastern side and the best spot for the
sunrise in the morning and to maintain
an
cool area for most of but what are you
doing anyway we get to stay effects
don't worry we're not going anywhere
let's go back over to Ellie see if she's
had any luck searching for the princess
well unfortunately no luck with the
tracks or the squirrels and everything
went quiet so we're just checking some
of the roads around just to see if we
could pick up anything for her just lots
of her you know trucks around seems like
Juma has just become a hyena central
well at least in terms of tracks so
unfortunately we haven't been able to
find anything we were also invoke a line
at one point looking for the cheetah
that was apparently spotted earlier on
but the last report was that they were
going north west from the boundary so I
think they did cross and then they are
unbuckles of excuse me somewhere now I
couldn't find any tracks because again
sometimes the directions we get are like
just go there maybe you'll see the
tracks and then we don't but yeah no
luck with that but you know it's a good
it's a good thing having them come every
now and again just sets up the
opportunity baby for one more ok sorry
guys it was just who was just trying to
get some view on the structure here but
I think it's just insects that have been
walking around up and down so who knows
could it be that perhaps sandy has gone
off and then she's left her around it is
quite thick around that area so it's a
little bit complicated to try and find
anything in there or it could also very
well be that tndi managed to make a
kill and then she moved her and they
went somewhere else further into the
block in which case it's a very big
block that one in which case I wouldn't
have had to come to any Road so that
would make our life a little bit
trickier so we'll see maybe a little bit
later on perhaps they'll come back to
the pans for water that will be pretty
good it is hot so there they have to
come for water at some point but the
challenge sometimes with this summer is
that when it rains there are a lot of
natural mud wallows in between the
blocks or wherever there are no roads so
for those animals like the leopards and
the Lions you don't really have to go to
big dams or anything I mean not just the
lines on the leopards any animal in
general they can't just have a drink
anywhere so he said what are those
tracks they're on your side sorry guys
we're trying to have a look at some
tracks that are on our left-hand side
you have a look yes I'm alright sorry
I'm gonna have one quick look just you
see in case we don't miss the
opportunity and it's a little bit of
soft sand all the way back here yeah I
think they're harina trucks yeah so
unfortunately I don't know if whoo it's
tricky to try and find a nice track to
show you guys I don't know if your zoom
comes all the way to here can you see
this one here at the bottom so this is
what we've been looking at so no there
we go now I've lost it so you see the
back pad is here there's one look here
and another one here and then of course
the fingers or the toes I should
actually say so there's one two three
four and then there's this little
inclination here this little dip here
where you can see where the claws wear
so when it stepped onto the and here you
can almost see where they brushed and
then there's another track here and then
another one here and then it's just
carried on going that way I would assume
that it's perhaps one of the juma clan
going back in that direction all they
have to do is pretty much go in a
straight line and it won't take them too
long to get there so all the tracks
around here hold Hanina tracks my guy
said we've we've bumped into a lot of
her you know tracks today but I think
it's good now that we know where the den
is cuz then that makes our lives easier
we know at least we're the ones with
little babies are gonna be long - let me
just plug myself in perfect I was hoping
cuz they were not too big that they were
gonna be electro track of course but
that unfortunately was not the case hmm
we're gonna carry on tracking see what
else we can find around here but while
we do that we'll send you guys back to
the actual hyenas
we do indeed have the high knees we can
guarantee them good luck trying to find
mrs. hell I'm a little princess and well
plunk continues to gorge on her mum and
they can they can suckle for an hour
hour and a half at a time giving them
some time to rest and I can't imagine
suckling for that amount of time really
really interesting indeed
the production of that milk and the two
to three times a day well sir should I
say off a dozen times six times a day in
the early months later on in life up to
three months can be about three times a
day it's a lot of time needed to by the
adults to spend sitting here with the
youngsters but the interesting thing
about the den is that they can leave
them completely unattended while the
guards and that's how the den actually
works TP know the skies around her neck
and head are bite marks scratches
possibly old tick bites things like that
the the biggest wounds she's received
are on her back we did see her when we
arrived yet but I didn't notice any
major injury her bottom was very wet I
assumed from the mud and the water she'd
been laying but I didn't notice the
seeping wound she had a really big
gaping wound on her back from the lion
and but it didn't I didn't notice that I
think she was at the wrong angle when I
saw her obscene my ear pieces just to
fall it out well she's being very
vigilant she probably still knows that
her Komori is somewhere nearby and I
suppose if you've ever been mauled by a
lion at all so make you sleep with one
eye open all the time there any only a
downfall of the position that we were in
now in seeing Corky and plunk having
it's having his meal her meal is that
well we're now in the Sun we were in a
really nice shady Street before look at
that isn't that just the cutest
and little spotted hyenas so she goes
from through moments of not having a
care in the world to raising her head in
alertness I don't know what it is that
she's hearing her plunk is turning
around oh trying to stand up come on
show us he wants to do it standing oh
look at the legs you are just being
ridiculous you know being ridiculous so
face is just too cute
spatchcock chicken indeed indeed it was
very fluffy stop as they lose a lot of
their fur as they get older you notice
that iene is up in the Maasai Mara or
much fluffier much more fur on the body
probably due to sort of the standardized
temperatures up there they can afford to
be a little bit for ya here the winters
get very very well get a relatively cold
but trainers can warm themselves up
through activity and the heat in the day
in the summer months is just probably
way too much for them to have too much
fur on them but the youngsters can
afford to have virtue to the fact that
they've got a much smaller body size and
so will give off a lot more heat they're
also not as active as the adults running
around so they need to have a little bit
of a jersey on them and Corky maybe if
you position himself a little bit better
plonk would ever better go at the
suckling seems like she doesn't want to
leave the safety of the hole too much
who knows if that's to do with her old
lion story but anyway it's much cooler
than the Masai Mara let's go and see if
David is got on his sugar
it's a lot cooler here than it is I'm
sure in Douma and sorry you lost me the
last time you had me because of some
technical issues and at a time now I'll
be getting on my shoe car and again as I
said we usually face a few challenges in
terms of bringing our best shows two
living rooms in your screens but then
sometimes things go wrong
anyhow I am back and I'm online and I
still say it's really getting chilly
here you can see from all the movement
or how all the wind is blowing the glass
the cross that indicates the
temperatures have gone down a minutes
ago I took a piece of paper and pen and
I was doing some notes and I was drawing
something on paper and Archie who is my
camera operator today was asking me what
I'm doing and I told him I'm trying to
connect all the dots the movement of the
source of the trip right because I know
where they actually where the ads were
or where they were a week ago and then I
could look at the possibilities of where
else they could go because I can't
understand why I cannot see them and you
know Archie told me good luck but I'm
sure well that's his way of trying to
get to my frustration out of myself like
where are they but now as you can see
one of the biggest challenges we have
currently now is this high grass and
those cuts could be 20 meters away from
where you are and imagining they're all
flats and about six inches high or eight
inches in looking at the hindquarters
you'll either keep driving and miss them
oh it could be anywhere else you know
but
Fiona you are talking of invasive plants
now if they are in in Mara luckily not
luckily not and the game Rangers are
very strict for when guests come here
they always encouraged not to come with
any live seeds or any live our safe
fruits where they could eat something
and throw it out there so Fiona the
grass we are seeing now this remains it
all around the yard has been like this
you know time immemorial and the most
dominant one here is what you call the
red ot glass or the remainder try Andrea
so that's my instrument and you're very
lucky we do not see any invasive or any
exotic species of plants now neighboring
the Mara there's another National Park
Unicode Serengeti National Park and
Serengeti National Park is in Tanzania
and every couple of months will always
see some fire you know man-made fire not
natural fire and their game rangers will
always light that particular area and
when you talk to them they'll tell you
they are trying to get rid of all the
bugs zero or the ticks mainly and also
just in case accidently there is an
exotic plant brought by a tourist or a
guest of some sort then they'll also
banish before it starts creeping and
taking over maybe their particular niche
or ecosystem of the surrogate world in
Kenya we don't do that but I'd say for a
fact this remains it's all the
well so say there's some running short
of time and again this is slowly coming
out to be my 2 out of 10 times or 10
days when they give me amis which is
fine this is to be the beauty of our job
you know we come expecting the
unexpected and also not to see their
business unexpected when you leave the
camp we always guaranteed I know where
they leave I know their territory I'm
gonna go looking at all the watering
points I'm gonna look where the animals
they can feed on for example buffaloes
or zebras Wow nature's nature and of
course they have their own rules but
what makes me laugh is trying to imagine
how many times have I passed the same
line you sleep in the same truck or
maybe how close were they as I was
driving and I did not see them and maybe
they put up their head after had passed
these smiles by David see you tomorrow
to this torture day you know it's very
possible it's very possible
so on the grounds we just have to drive
pretty carefully slowly and hoping they
might pop up because the last place they
had a kill they stayed in an open area
you know in the grass for about three
days and they did not move from there
for those three days
all right you still have a few more
minutes to keep her chancing my luck but
I think Steve's hyenas are telling him
Bob you're lucky boy today
good luck Gigi I'm sure you will find
the Lions they're out there somewhere
although they did evade you yesterday
there's a very big area licking her lips
and satisfaction she long has been
standing trying to stand and Corki keeps
pulling him down and he wants to stand
and eat because I think he's a little
bit more upside down I mean he's lying
down and now every time he does so she
grabs him with her paw and pushes him
down again her Dan I can't remember if
she's a if clonk is a male or female
I've been trying to find out in my in my
I'm on my phone here but I'm in such a
bad signal area that I'm not getting any
of the information Emma thinks seems to
remember plonk is a boy I thought that
as well but I couldn't remember and I
don't want to get it wrong but I know
many of you out there are very familiar
with these animals most of the time that
plunk and the other two youngsters have
been around I was in the mara so I
didn't really get to spend too much time
with them I just started learning the
owners up there seems an insurmountable
task and now we are back down here
there's Koki decides to give the anal
pouch another grooming hmm
thanks everyone for confirming there
that he is indeed a boy very naughty
little boy a very cute boy in fact so
it's interesting I mean all the debates
that range around matriarch sand they
offspring in we will that is sort of
land in the social grouping of things
and you know things have changed of the
years everyone's always said males have
no standing but it's become quite true
to life that males indeed if they're
born you're made shocking Heritage
status or Oh
Corky's dad that was very ungracious oh
look at him mom I'm hungry it's got very
nice long legs isn't he just gorgeous
he's grown inches skinny still got a bit
of loose skin on the forehead was given
that sea cocky he doesn't seem to have
too much in the way of injuries on her
at the moment they sue bottom ok well
let's have a listen as some noise is
going on yet
[Music]
he's not done but I think she's done who
are you calling in the hole there Corky
who did you want to come out and say
hello she's going Safari laughs here
people come and say hello to them
I've got a bit of a limp on her they I
think because she's been lying down but
you know I saw her this morning and she
looked fine I didn't see any marks on it
let's see on the other side it seems to
be completely healed isn't that
remarkable remarkable she had the
nastiest of wounds on her back there I'm
trying to look closely it's hard to tell
really this is mud incredible incredible
that must be two months three months now
she's decided she would like to sit in
the beautiful Feathertop Cloris she's
going look I'm a leopard everybody take
my photograph now I'm in the beautiful
grass this is where you take photos of
all the leopards don't you obviously
after a genital licking first of all
because she needs to look her best
clunk what are you smelling there's must
be so many sounds or smells going on in
the hyena nose there it can they can
pick up enormous amounts of things in
the air be quite overwhelming when
they're quite young you've ever taken a
dog for a drive and they stick their
head out the window you can't really
even talk to them because they're
completely absorbed with what they are
smelling some oxpeckers there got her to
lift her head
well we've got two members here and I
want an individual walks away probably
went to go and have a little bit of a
bath it might be Tom oh there we go
mummy give me an ear licking what would
you do with that Mama remember that's
one of the things I was always told when
as a child is don't forget to wash
behind your ears my anus don't have to
remember because their mums do it for
them right there there's hard-to-reach
places
oh I don't know if that's lovely or
disgusting because you can you imagine
the breath that is coming off of Corky's
mouth right now how that is supposed to
be cleaning your son's head I'm not
quite sure but I think at least a
hundred percent or a for effort we
should say a for effort yeah I think
cork you still know is that who Kumari
was around she keeps looking in the
direction that he disappeared in - she's
probably thinking is he had to come back
and give my little baby any trouble okay
well anyway we're going to stay here
we're not going anywhere
let's go back over to James I think he's
still checking at the watering holes
we don't have much of an update I'm
afraid except that we've managed to find
Ally and Trish Allah and where will
Sebastian marvelous let's have a quick
word with him
hello no luck
I'm afraid right well we didn't hear you
and all your the lines there okay well
then I'll suggest you stick with him
okay all right I'm going to run down to
Chitra give lavon's goodbye look right
everybody well today is a very special
day for some people around the world of
course given that there are 7 billion of
us occupying this planet you can be
fairly sure that some people were born
and in fact have been born on this day
now one of those people is a mr. Daniel
Souter an enormous super duper uber
ultra infra fan and well happy birthday
Daniel I know that you managed to find
Emily and Graham or they've managed to
find you or something rather you met up
with them and well it's your birthday
today and so a very happy birthday to
you I'm sorry we can't give you slightly
more than Greenbush and sand at the
moment to show you but Steve's done an
admirable job and so does Ali I suppose
of showing you some of our favorite two
characters and I hope that they have
been sufficient for your 43rd birthday
gosh you are really are quite old almost
eight months older than I on ancient
human being yes I am that is absolutely
correct
okay what we're gonna do now is head
down towards towards Chitra Dam because
that's where we going to stop the TV
show and I'm afraid calamba has managed
to give us the sleep there's a lot of
thick bush around here there are very
few water pipes and we've checked
absolutely every one of them we just
haven't been lucky so we're gonna have
one more check of Gouri pan on our way
down and then give it up for three
shallots and Ali anyway alright let's go
back to David and let's find out it had
any luck finding the sauce Sasha's
well James I'm not any better than you
and I do not have anybody to is happy
but legend but just two ish these
campers if you know them if they just
want to show off their faces for couple
minutes before we end the show or Chris
the amaavas
all the males the old Anya pike males
none of them is trying to be very
friendly today but I would understand
because I would say almost the whole of
this year began we have seen them almost
every other day now they take a break
from us it was the case fine are well
understood and we'll give them a break
from our cheese camera is the camera
mounted which day and if that's the case
then that's fine so we'll be here
tomorrow the day after we're not going
anywhere and this particular area is one
area was at the beginner they are
looking for the same lights and found
the ship or whatever tree here the male
leopard are all this area so it could be
either it's because this is apparently
his territory the leopard he lives
around this area
and I saw him eating with one unknown
female a female that we do not know and
I'm assuming that female might have
conceived and if that happened at the
beginning they may be going to the end
of next month
we might be lucky to see a cat or two
and I think the person whose luck has
been doing very well today is Steve oval
oh geez the winner of today you say well
there's been a fantastic day and a day
that I'm into remember because we're
going to employ the magic quarry trick
because it works very very well
well Corky went off for a little meander
probably to have a drink she walked
straight to that little pan and then she
came back postulated herself for a
little plunk and now he's popped out
again and he is now eating or should I
say suckling isn't that just so cute
little mini version little mini version
of her so Corky very good idea
positioning your den very close to some
water that was very smart thinking Donna
most certainly do make it again flea
infested probably mites as well all
sorts of things are moving in a in there
and so that's one of the reasons why I
eNOS will move to insights is to lower
those parasites the ability to go
through a number of life cycles and then
possibly perish because if they stayed
here the life cycle of the parasite
would just continue within the den and
the animal would never get rid of those
parasites I'm not gonna say that hyenas
are ever rid of parasites but you have
the ability to decrease loads and
increase loads and by staying in one den
site it would definitely definitely
increase it's the same as when humans
first started living in one place things
started getting a little bit disgusting
and that's when the first sicknesses and
plagues started because of obviously the
decaying food the lack of waste disposal
and all of those things that lead to the
many many many illnesses that we still
see in rural parts of the world where
there's not sanitary conditions where
they are rodent outbreaks and where
there is obviously the lack of a
distribution or clean water so it is a
similar sort of process the hyenas walk
obviously I'm not gonna get dysentery by
staying in
a termite mound but the smell and the
parasites and the Flies possibly that
are attracted as well as the ticks and
fleas well they will just follow the
hyenas and constantly be breeding on
them and sucking their blood if they
don't move well it seems like plunk is
going to fill his belly with much-needed
milk that Sun has gone behind a few
clouds making it a beautiful beautiful
afternoon now Kathy the magic quarry
there's a lot to be said for the magic
quarry and well we're going to employ
that technique more from now on because
it has been a fantastic day
Missy spending time with her koumori
most of the morning and he led us to the
den site I know many of you out there
are super excited that we've managed to
find them everyone at the morning
meeting table this morning was also very
blessed because we have got we have got
a TV show coming on in the next half an
hour 45 minutes and while we had Okumura
he's gone south and we had 10 Ghana he's
gone south we've got the Goomer bride
they are south of the boundary so
without these years I don't really know
what are we going to talk about but
anyway we got lots of things to talk
about and Cal six you reckon I should
use the magic quarry bronze to attract
Hosanna well I will do that so I'm going
to hang a branch from my door and I'm
going to take on an every drive and
hopefully ting the little chief will
come back hello cookie it's nice to see
you again very nice to see you and she
is very happy to see all of you ladies
and gentlemen a little bit of a cut on
the side of her face there a little bit
of blood maybe she got a smack from a
leopard there that seems to be a little
bit of a wound maybe there was a tick
there they got plucked off everyone is
agreeing is happy to have the Juma clan
back Andra mer indeed is very happy to
be spending some time with him such Pro
close proximity to one of the most
magnificent predators on the African
continent the most complex
anyway and nice to be able to spend time
and to really delve into the behaviors
that they exhibit well everybody I hope
you've had a wonderful afternoon of acid
has gone from being very hot to being
nice and cool we are going to be closing
shortly for an S ABC show but thank you
for joining us this afternoon we will
see you again a bright and early
tomorrow morning I hope you've had a
good weekend have a beautiful beautiful
evening and we will see you tomorrow
morning
good day and goodbye
[Music]